in our last video we talked about mikala
the unalloyed
so it's only natural for this video that
we talk about his twin sister
but before we talk about the demigod
herself
you must first know about the rot that
afflicts her
the scarlet rot
it is a manifestation of the will of a
sealed outer god
and there are legends that imply that
the demigod we're about to talk about
may have been the one that sealed this
outer god within herself
but this is not entirely true i believe
they are just that
legends
the rot had existed long before the
demigods birth
the giant insects that we see through
the underground of the lands between
seem to be associated with this outer
god
and before the birth of the twin
prodigies the scarlet rot was already a
legend associated with the cycle of
decay and rebirth
although very few like those of the
mariah's house truly believed in such a
legend
but when the scarlet ionia first bloomed
they would then have their goddess
the blade of mykola millennia the
severed
like her brother melania is an emperian
born from queen marika the eternal and
ratigan of the golden order
from birth millennia was afflicted with
the scarlet rock despite being the
daughter of a god and having the full
power of the golden order they could do
nothing to cure it
in her body the scarlet ront wishes to
break free and bloom her into a true
goddess
while it wasn't clear when she started
rotting it may have been early in
melania's life as even when she was
first learning the sword she already had
prosthetics on her body
indeed she learned the sword from a
master whose blade curved like water and
his attacks imitated a dance like no
other
in fact you can wield a sword similar to
that of her master and its attacks
resemble that of the waterfowl dance
that is a skill on melania's blade
from this master she would learn to
wield her sword but it is through her
own strength that she would become
undefeated
the kershi bore would attract the
children of roth they would come to see
melania as a prophet and a potential
goddess
but she would turn away from the call of
the rot
choosing instead to protect her brother
the children of rot would see this as
abandonment something we'll circle back
to later
unfortunately despite her strength and
perseverance to resist the scarlet rot
it would ultimately take her slowly
gouging her eyes and rotting body parts
off
prosthetics would be made for her body
first created by the marais house who
specialized in creating those due to
their family being frail and sickly the
marais house would even come to worship
melania in the future as their goddess
of rot
her suffering would greatly affect her
brother more than her though as mykola
could not stand the sight of her
sister's suffering which would
eventually lead him to abandon the
fundamentalism of the golden order to
find a way to cure the scarlet rot
mikala would leave for the north and
melania would join him towards his
hailing tree
it was mikala who would gift melania
with her current valkyries prosthetics a
creation of analog gold
the prosthetics would be so great that
it can be used as proficiently as real
body parts
melania would swear to her brother to be
his blade
which is how she came to carry the title
blade of mykola
and i have never known defeat
during the shattering she would also go
to war and she would claim a great rune
for herself
one that should have been the most
sacred of all the great runes if not for
her scarlet rock
the knights who followed her to battle
would be the most fearsome of all the
knights in the land
for to follow the goddess of rot would
mean to take the scarlet rot within
yourself
this would lead to a slow and painful
death
petrifaction of the flesh would make the
knights no longer fear death and they
would fight with want and disregard
they would come to be known as the clean
rot knights but though they were knights
their minds and bodies were barely kept
stable by their consecrated armor but on
the eve of any battle the clean rot
knights themselves would remain the most
fearsome enemies
they would remain undefeated during the
shattering and to clash with them would
mean to clash with death itself
melania would conquest throughout the
lands between and through her sword
skills alone she would be undefeated
during the early battles of the
shattering she humiliated godric the
grafton in the battle of limgrave
causing him to cower in fear
perhaps a wise choice with what happened
to their neighbor in kaelin
for in kaelin she would be faced with
general radon
the star scourge
who would prove to be more than her
match
their armies would clash and the most
fearsome battle of the shattering would
begin
they would meet upon the fields of
kaelin radon would meet her measure with
gravity and strength
and they would be locked into a
stalemate with their blades
radon was holding the stars in place
and melania was keeping the scarlet rot
at bay
but
melania would throw away her pride her
dignity her will to resist the scarlet
rot
in order to claim victor
instead of beating radon with her blade
she would embrace the rot within bloom
the flowers and unleash the scarlet
ionia upon caled
this would be the first time the scarlet
ionia bloomed in the lands between
and it would destroy the entire region
as well as afflict radon with scarlet
wrong
radon would lose himself his mind rotted
from the inside and his hunger
insatiable
this act however would put melania to
sleep
and it is only by the heroism of the
legendary clean rot knight finley that
she would even be able to return to the
heilig tree
melania would claim victory for this
battle because most of radon's army
would succumb to the rot and radhaan
would cease to be himself
despite this the remainder of his army
would continue their battle in red main
castle
using fire to burn away the rot
and radon would be left to wander the
scarlet desert
nothing but a husk of his former self
from this point forward melania would be
asleep next to the roots of the heilig
tree
until a certain tarnish
destined to be elden lord would wake her
the blooming of the scarlet ionia would
echo throughout the lands between
and would cause chaos within caled from
here the children of roth would come out
from their dens beneath the earth and
would celebrate the birth of their
goddess
thus becoming the order of rot
we talked about the legend of the
scarlet rot at the start of the video
the legend itself was a reality and the
order of roth long existed before
melania's bloom
and while they didn't think of melania
as their goddess from the start due to
her abandon
after she bloomed she proved her beauty
this next part is a bit more open to
speculation
but i believe that gauri would come to
create children using the scarlet ionia
and the so-called children of melania
are not truly hers
and instead are but a cheap copy created
by the children of rot or gauri
specifically
four sisters would be created before
perfection could be attained
millicent would be the perfected
daughter of gauri
she would walk the same path as melania
and suffer all the same
but
unlike melania
milicent would not be able to withstand
the scarlet rock it would put her in
agony unable to make her journey
it is at this moment gowrie would seek
your help to obtain one of nicholas
unalloyed needles
the needle would help millicent and
enable her to follow the footsteps of
melania albeit with a lot of help from
the tarnished
we would help her along the way to the
heilig tree
a few sequences stick out during this
quest
such as gauri's mention of millicent
being a bud that would bloom into a
flower
and that her sisters before her were all
inferior in quality
and millicent talking about what she
needs to return to melania
her pride to me this shows that melania
knew not to bloom the flowers to keep
her pride as a warrior but in order to
remain undefeated to perhaps have a
sense of usefulness despite her ailing
body or even something darker
she would cast away the needle and
needless things such as pride for the
sake of her dearest michela
the order of rot would join michela's
hailing tree and it would seem that
despite their difference they would find
friendship within the covenant of the
twin prodigies
and once we arrived to the hailing tree
with millicent she would come to
understand what her journey was for
it was the call of the scarlet rot
for her to bloom as a scarlet valkyrie
but just like her mother
she would reject this call
and would instead face her sisters close
to the roots of the hailing tree
we would have a choice to help her or
betray her
and after helping her defeat her four
sisters
she would show the effects of the rot
for she had removed the tainted befowled
needle that was given to her
she understood that she was being led
astray
to become different from who she was
to die and bloom as rot
instead she chose to die as herself as
who she believed herself to be
as millicent
she would give the needle to you
now clear of any taint
she asks that you return the needle to
melania
as she is taken by the scarlet rot
eventually the tarnished would reach the
slumbering demigod at the roots of the
hailing tree
we find melania still asleep before we
could even approach
a gust of wind that may have been mikala
would wake her ready for battle
an ideal time to look at her closely
her left arm seems to be embedded with
analog gold to prevent it from rotting
further
her right arm completely removed her
eyes completely rotted and both her legs
rotted off as well
as the great tarnish that you are
you would prove to be more than a match
for her
and once again she would be forced to
bloom
she would release the scarlet ionia upon
you her form forever changed as she
approaches godhood once more
but even then
the tarnish will not be overturned
even though you are tarnished of no
renown your blade is hardened and strong
and through the sheer unimaginable skill
of the tarnished destined to be elden
lord that you are
you would claim victory in the face of
the undefeated
her passing would leave behind the
flower of scarlet rot and you may return
the needle milicent gave you
and here obtain the near-perfect needle
of michela
returning to gauri will have him lament
over millicent's death
failing to bloom as a scarlet flower
however
should you have chosen to betray
millicent
should you have strayed from the path
and delivered unto her the defeat galrie
wanted
she would have bloomed into a scarlet
flower like no other
much like the flower now that sits in
the roots of the hailing tree
perhaps there is a reason why melania
aspired to be undefeated
the scarlet rot is a cycle of decay and
rebirth
with death as a part of that cycle
do we truly realize what we may have
done
you